couplé mais bien monté forcément on n'a
pas encore tous les chiffres officiels
c'est très difficile bourreau n'est
jamais d âme et loi finalement c'est le
confinement dans le confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux endroits à 3
[Musique]
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre elle les musées avec trois mois
de non activité où les billetteries sont
à l'arrêt l'impact financier est énorme
ce sera un rare démarche sous conditions
1 avec port du masque obligatoire
distanciation physique gestion des flux
de ce que nous attendons c'est
effectivement la possibilité de rouvrir
sans ces mesures barrières le plus vite
possible
on retrouvera pas le marché que nous
avons quitté en 2021
il faudra reconstruire le marché ça
prendra plusieurs mois voire plusieurs
années
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités toujours tenus à bonne distance
et nos reporters voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 29 juin
les républicains font part de leur
stupéfaction après la condamnation qu'il
qualifie de terriblement lourde pour le
couple fillon avec le troisième prévenu
marc joulaud ils ont été jugés coupables
dans la sphère d'en haut est fictif cinq
ans de prison dont deux ferme requis
pour l'ex premier ministre avec trois
ans de sursis pour son épouse
dacourt a par ailleurs refuser la
réouverture des débats demandée par la
défense emmanuel macron donne le feu
vert il a reçu à l'elysée les 150
membres de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat le chef de l'état annonce un
projet de loi reprenant une large part
de leurs propositions et 15 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires dédiés à la
transformation écologique et
propositions qui interviennent au
lendemain des municipales marquées par
une vague verte
les écologistes emporte dans plusieurs
grandes villes comme lyon bordeaux ou
strasbourg
à deux jours de la présidence allemande
de l'union européenne emmanuel macron
rencontre angela merkel ce lundi pour
discuter de la relance économique au
château de meseberg à côté de berlin les
deux dirigeants a fuit leur argumentaire
ils doivent convaincre les 25 entre pays
d'adopter le plan de relance de 750
milliards d'euros d'euros
dawn être nie tout en bloc tout comme
moscou et les talibans des démentis qui
interviennent à la suite d'un article du
new york times qui affirme que la russie
aurait permis aurait versé des primes
aux talibans pour tuer des soldats
américains et de l'otan en afghanistan
pour le président américain il s'agit
d'une nouvelle tentative pour lui nuire
à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle
[Musique]
le verdict était très attendu les époux
fillon et le troisième prévenu marc
joulaud ont donc été déclarées coupables
dans les fers des emplois fictifs
le couple fait appel de sa condamnation
et comme l'avaient demandé les avocats
de la défense les débats ne seront pas
rouverts les précisions devant le
tribunal correctionnel de paris avec
notre reporter katia pique nique
il n'y a pas eu de miracle un pas de
relaxe comme l'espéraient les avocats
des trois prévenus l'ancien premier
ministre a été condamné à cinq ans de
prison dont deux ferme une peine qui
risquait de ne pas être aménageable il a
en outre été condamné à 375000 euros
d'amendé et dix ans d'inéligibilité
quant à son épouse pénélope fillon elle
a écopé de la même amende et de trois
ans de prison avec sursis
marc joulaud lui a été condamné à trois
ans de prison avec sursis également et à
verser 20 mille euros damende les trois
prévenus devront également verser plus
d'un million d'euros à l'assemblée
nationale les avocats des prévenus ont
dénoncé des conditions selon eux
scandaleuse dans lesquelles s'était
ouvert le procès ils ont immédiatement
fait appel je vous propose les écouter
c'est une décision extrêmement sévère
qui a été rendue
en ce qui concerne pénélope fillon il
avait également remarqué que le tribunal
ne contesté pas qu'elle avait rendu des
services en tant que collaboratrice de
son mari qu'elle avait accompli les
tâches qu'elle avait participé à des
manifestations mais le tribunal
contrairement à ce que nous lui
demandions a considéré qu'il avait le
pouvoir de s'immiscer dans l'activité du
parlementaire naturellement cette
décision qui n'est pas juste va être
frappée d'appel et nous allons enfin et
j'espère avec tous les éléments qui
manque au dossier avec les instructions
individuelles qui n'ont jamais été
versés avec les rapports fantômes qui
n'ont jamais été communiqué avec ces
réunions d'arrière boutique à laquelle
la défense n'a jamais été convié
peut-être qu'en possession de tous ses
éléments qu'il est temps que la justice
verse aux débats
on pourra enfin avoir un débat complet
et serein et permettre enfin à la
justice d'être rendue
la présidente du tribunal correctionnel
a donc suivi à peu près le réquisitoire
de mars
elle s'est montrée particulièrement
sévère en lisant en énumérant les
nombreuses inconsistance da la
collaboration de pénélope fillon en tant
qu'assistante parlementaire selon elle
elle ne traitaient aucun dossier est
donc la rémunération n'était pas en
rapport avec le travail effectué en
revanche est bien tout l'enveloppent
parlementaires étaient mobilisés pour
pénélope fillon
même chose pour les enfants du couple
qui était employé par françois fillon
alors qu'il ne pouvait pas travailler
puisqu'il suivait leurs études
quant à la collaboration avec la revue
des deux mondes et bien selon la
présidente il s'agissait juste d'un
emploi de complaisance
selon elle françois fillon orchestré
tous ces mécanismes en connaissance de
cause il a contribué à éroder le lien de
confiance entre les français et leurs
représentants politiques alors les
peines sont lourdes mais difficile de
lire les réactions du couple fillon qui
avait évidemment le visage masqué un
parent un masque chirurgical
en revanche voici pour les pilotes
provisoire de cette affaire car les
avocats ont fait appel et alors que la
déclaration de l'ex procureur du parquet
national financiers
une lettre le 10 juin dernier avait à
nouveau jeter le trou et la suspicion
dans cette affaire la justice at-elle
joué son rôle
huo réguler aurait-elle dû ajourner le
procès est elle véritablement était
indépendante ou est elle instruit à
charge comme le dénonce en tout cas
aujourd'hui les républicains
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec yves d'amécourt conseiller
régional et les publicains de nouvelles
aquitaine à vos côtés yves d'amécourt
denis demonpion éditorialiste politique
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
heures direct avec nous sur rt france 50
prison on le rappelle dont deux ferme
dix ans d'inéligibilité 375000 euros
damende en tout cas contre françois
fillon les républicains ce soir yves
d'amécourt dénoncé une peine très lourde
est ce que c'est votre cas aussi bien
sûr c'est une peine très lourde qui est
sans commune mesure avec les faits
reprochés et puis derrière tout ça il ya
l'action d'un parquet national financier
qui a été construit de toutes pièces en
fait pour chasser sur les terres de des
opposants de françois hollande on a
aujourd'hui les révélations des lianes
houlette qui nous explique elle a été
sous la pression de la procureure
générale pour accélérer la procédure et
chacun s'est bien rendu compte que
jamais le candidat françois fillon
n'aurait dû être mis en examen avant
l'élection présidentielle
tout ça est allé très vite il ya quinze
jours le les mêmes les mêmes magistrats
jugent à une affaire de 1993 et
aujourd'hui on juge une affaire qui a
été très très vite et chacun chacun
aujourd'hui peut peut juger par lui même
que la justice n'est pas juste denis
demonpion peines lourdes pour françois
fillon on va évidemment parler dans ce
débat en détail mais effectivement de la
suspicion une
décision qui s'est rendu peut-être dans
des conditions compliquées avec la
déclaration de l'ex procureur le 10 juin
aurait coûté il faut bien distinguer
deux choses déjà on peut pas que
déplorer que la justice soit aller vite
alors que généralement on a tendance à
déplorer sa lenteur et je pense que le
tribunal qui a statué aujourd'hui l'a
fait au vu des pièces qui avaient été
versés au dossier pour une part du
dossier n'est ce pas pour reprocher à
pénélope fillon dans le cadre de la
revue des deux mondes vous savez où
elles avaient été salariées par le
président de la revue marc ladreit de
lacharrière alors même qu'elle n'avait
produit que deux petites chroniques qui
était un petit peu suspecte quant à
l'authenticité
bon vous savez que dans ce dossier marc
ladreit de lacharrière lui-même a plaidé
coupable dans une procédure à part et
donc ça entraîné mathématiquement la
condamnation de pénélope fillon
donc sur ce cet aspect des choses
voilà il n'y a pas grand chose à en dire
ensuite pour ce qui est des de l'emploi
fictif qui est reprochée pennac fillon
comme assistante parlementaire
on peut quand même rappeler aussi que
j'entendais les avocats là qui disait
qu'il verserait des pièces au dossier
les rapports dont la justice aurait fait
abstraction etc
il faut quand même rappeler que dans une
déclaration publique journal britannique
elle avait déclaré qu' elle n'avait
jamais travaillé pour son mari et que
même elle n'avait jamais rencontré ses
collaborateurs donc il ya quand même une
petite suspicion pour le moins quant à
la peine qui a été prononcée
non il n'est pas très surprenante il
faut se souvenir que dans un cas
précédent toujours d'ailleurs pour des
questions de prêts fictifs on se
souvient qu alain juppé
alors même qu'il avait travaillé pour la
mairie de paris il était secrétaire
secrétaire général du rpr à l'époque
l'ancêtre des républicains il avait été
en première instance condamné lui aussi
à dix ans d'inéligibilité et à une très
lourde peine de prison
accompagné de sursis et ferme pour une
partie donc là il ya un appel
yves d'amécourt 1 c'est vrai que des
affaires voilà d'attaché parlementaire
il y en a beaucoup l'assemblée nationale
mediapart je donne quelques chiffres on
a relevé voilà 58 et pose rémunérés en
2014 28 6 32 sites députés au moins 20%
de nos élus aurait rémunéré un proche
ça veut dire qu'on voudrait en faire
selon vous un exemple de françois fillon
le moment était charnière le problème
c'est quand la justice n'est pas
équitable et donc effectivement au
moment de la sphère fillon mediapart
avait comptabilisé sept ans entre en
terre qui avait élémentaire de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat et que
c'était illégal pour les parlementaires
de du parlement européen et donc la
sphère était légale bizarrement alors
que ces informations ont été rendues
publiques par mediapart
personne n'a été poursuivi je pense
d'ailleurs à bruno le maire qui est
notre actuel ministre de l'économie dont
l'épousé est artiste peintre et qui a
été branché pendant cinq ans à son
service à l'assemblée nationale c'est
curieux alors que cette information est
publique
il ya eu deux ou trois articles dans la
presse que la justice ne s'intéresse que
au cas de françois fillon président
candidat à l'élection présidentielle et
pas aux autres dossiers de zagné
d'emplois fictifs
au même moment au moment où françois
fillon est inquiété au moment où il ya
les premières fuites dans le canard
enchaîné de quelque chose qui était
officiel puisque les salaires de
françois fillon était officielle est
déclarée et que les le couple film toy
et de ses impôts anne hidalgo qui était
poursuivi pour soupçon d'emplois fictifs
pour m
le ministère des solidarités
elle n'a pas été mis en examen et a
bénéficié de la prescription
le 27 février avec l'entrée en vigueur
de la loi
fenech est donc l'accélération qui a été
mise en place à la demande du procureur
général
et on se demande aujourd'hui si ce
n'était pas aussi à la demande de jean
jacques urvoas et de françois hollande
pour que françois fillon soit bien mis
en examen avant le 25 février avant que
cette question ne rentre en vigueur
ce n'est pas équitable puisqu'il y avait
plusieurs dossiers à ce moment là et que
ça le dossier très de françois fillon a
fait l'objet d'une telle à distance et
d'une telle cure et pour reprendre les
termes de d'un juriste récemment denis
demonpion effectivement on peut se
demander si la justice peut être rendue
sereinement dans ces conditions monsieur
d'amécourt vient nous rappeler les
circonstances évidemment qui ont coûté
peut-être la présidentielle françois
fillon en tout cas il était bien parti
on rappelait que c'était un candidat
type totalisé 63 % des intentions de
vote à la présidentielle en novembre
2016 là il ya eu cette sortie de l'ex
procureur le 10 juin
dans ces conditions est ce que les juges
dans le système actuel peuvent rendre un
verdict vraiment serein il ya deux
choses d'abord le parquet au cssa dette
pas de françois fillon
il est de fait ce sont les textes de loi
rattaché au ministère de la justice au
pouvoir quel qu'il soit hier comme
aujourd'hui il ya eu des discussions
souvient d'ailleurs du temps de jacques
chirac quand il celui ci était président
de la république pour savoir s'il
fallait couper le fameux cordon
ombilical entre le parquet et le pouvoir
politique dont il en a été décisive a
été décidé que nyon puisque le pouvoir
politique voulait avoir un certain
regard sur la justice sur l'accusation
ce qui est le cas dans toutes les
procédures sensibles
mais il faut aussi ajouter que les juges
du siège qui eux statut endroit après
examen du dossier avoir écouté d'abord
les prévenus les avocats de la défense
des parties civiles s'il y en a
l'accusation par la voix du procureur
dit stature en toute indépendance et en
toute liberté
d'ailleurs ils sont nommés de manière un
peu distinctes et les juges du siège
comme on les appelle sont totalement
indépendants jusqu'à plus ample informé
je ne sache pas que une décision comme
ça et été prise sous pression de qui que
ce soit ça n'existe pas ça n'existe pas
d'aimer quand c'est votre avis également
eric ciotti oui je sais pas si vous avez
entendu
l'audition sous serment du juge renaud
van ruymbeke par la commission denquête
de l'assemblée nationale qui est
présidée par un député de la france
insoumise renaud van ruymbeke a dit sous
serment
j'ai appris sur bfm tv la nomination des
trois juges sur la sphère fillon
j'ai dit à mon épouse ça ça m'étonnerait
bien si c'était le cas je serais au
courant et donc la vérité c'est que ces
juges ont été choisis à dessein que ils
ont été saoul saisi le 15 jours pour que
ce soit les juges de garde et on sait
très bien la réputation du juge
tournaire dans la justice et son
indépendance
car honnêtement elle est peut-être
indépendante du pouvoir mais elle n'est
pas indépendante des idéologies et cette
semaine denis de montures le juge
tournaire qui a une réputation voilà
d'hommes de goce est ce que c'est
quelque chose on peut contester
dany de manquement il se trouve que dans
le trip tué sujet était d'abord présidé
par une président n'est ce pas le juge
d'instruction était effectivement le
juge tournaire qui a qui étaient censés
instruire à charge et à décharge l'objet
quand un juge d'instruction
instruit à charge les avocats de la
défense sont là pour le rappeler à
l'ordre
et pour engager batailler au c'est à
dire faire appel se tourner vers la cour
jusqu'à aller jusqu'à la cour de
cassation si besoin
donc il est difficile de faire le procès
d'une juridiction indépendante
au vu des déclarations d'un procureur
quand bien même il s'agit de l'ancien
procureur du parquet financier et d'un
juge d'instruction qui sans doute est
peut-être à cesser ses opinions
politiques
et je ne dis pas qu'il a toujours
d'ailleurs instruit en tout
comment dirais-je l'absence d'idéologie
mais ça c'est à démontrer en tout cas
quand il s'agit de juger une affaire
comme ça a été le cas dans cette affaire
fillon
les juges ne sont pas suspects et
d'ailleurs il suffit de reprendre la
carrière et le pedigree de chacun on ne
peut pas les suspects et de parti-pris
innovant appliquer la loi
d'ailleurs l'avocat de françois fillon
antonin lévy a immédiatement dit qu'il
serait fait appel des dix ans
d'inéligibilité et évidemment de la
chronique de la deûle à de la prison
avec sursis et fermes qui ont été
prononcées et la cour d'appel statuera
alors si si effectivement les avocats et
françois fillon lui même sont en mesure
d'apporter des pièces qui leur auraient
échappé jusque là bas très bien ligue en
sera tenu compte des visites dans ce
premier procès a déposé un appel je vous
coupe c'est la fin de ce débat merci
denis demonpion merci également à yves
d'amécourt on verra ce que va donner en
tout cas l'appel puisque y aura un
deuxième procès fillon merci à tous les
deux d'avoir accepté ce face à face ce
soir merci beaucoup
[Musique]
les élections municipales à présent les
verts ont remporté plusieurs grandes
villes de france en tête dans de
nombreuses villes après le premier tour
les écologistes ont confirmé leur
exploit hier malgré une abstention
record le parti vert s'impose comme
première force locale face aux partis
traditionnels
une victoire écrasante qui tranchent
beaucoup avec elle et défaite du parti
présidentiel
les précisions grégoire douce et une
vague verte déferle sur la france
les écologistes se sont emparés de
plusieurs grandes villes ce dimanche une
journée marquée par une abstention
historiquement haute
ce sont environ 6 électeurs sur dix
appelé aux urnes qui ne se sont pas
rendus dans leurs bureaux de vote
qu'importe pour europe ecologie les
verts qui s'impose au sortir de ces
élections comme le nouveau poids lourd
de la gauche sur l'échiquier politique
français à lyon le triomphe est total
la métropole revient à bruno bernard et
la ville à grégory douce et au nez et à
la barbe du camp de gérard collomb
ancien ministre de l'intérieur d'
emmanuel macron et maire de la capitale
des gaules durant près de deux décennies
lyon apaisé cela signifie qu'on a le
devoir de protéger la santé celle des
humains mais aussi celle de tous les
êtres sensibles de tout ce qui vit de
tout ce qui pousse de tous ceux qui
bruissent car nous avons besoin les uns
des autres
lyon troisième ville de france a le
devoir de tracer le chemin celui de la
transition écologique et de l'humanisme
la bascule s'opère également à
strasbourg et bordeaux qui passe sous
pavillon écolo dans la capitale
girondine
pierre hurmic arrache la victoire d'une
courte tête si à marseille le succès de
l'écologiste michèle ruby rola à la tête
d'une coalition de gauche est encore
incertain anne hidalgo guerre de son
siège à l'hôtel de ville de paris
après avoir mené une campagne résolument
verte vous avez choisi l'espoir vous
avez choisi le rassemblement vous avez
choisi un pari qui respire un pari plus
agréable à vivre une ville plus
solidaire qui ne laisse personne sur le
bord du chemin
le revers est lourd en revanche pour la
république en marche
le parti majoritaire à l'assemblée
nationale no glane aucune grande ville à
l'exception du havre dont les habitants
ont réélu le premier ministre edouard
philippe
un tournant vert à prendre en compte
pour le président emmanuel macron qui
devrait prochainement fixé le cap de la
fin de son mandat et pour parler de ces
municipales nous sommes avec joaquim
pueyo député ps de l'orne élu maire
d'alençon hier bon soir en direct sur
arte france alors tout d'abord les
félicitations à son sombre rigueur vous
retrouvez votre fauteuil de maire alors
sentez vous la pression écologiste sur
écologique sur vos épaules
je ne sais pas si une pression
écologique mais je crois que c'est une
nécessité en fait et dans la liste que
j'ai conduit on avait pris également des
engagements pour que la ville dont
lequel je viens d'être élu soit une
ville plus durable plus écologique
également héros doit renforcer la
transition écologique donc c'est une
nécessité et j'ai proposé dix
engagements
moi je ne suis pas parti avec
l'étiquette écologiste puisque j'ai
conduit une liste divers gauche je suis
parti socialiste et il y avait lors de
ce deuxième tome nice également soutenu
par le par l'europe écologie les verts
mais dans vos programmes
j'avais cette nécessité d'ailleurs quand
j'étais maire j'avais mis en place
également deux agendas 21 ha en 2009
j'avais par exemple interdit des
pesticides sur les espaces publics
et puis un deuxième en 2014 on avait
effectivement pris des mesures pour
mieux protéger notre environnement pour
le mettre en valeur également et pour
par exemple dans dans les énergies on
est mis en place une chaufferie bois par
exemple même deux en l'espace de 7 8 ans
donc c'est une nécessité c'est pas une
pression je crois que ça ça correspond
effectivement aux défis de demain je pas
que le réchauffement climatique
il ya une aura des conséquences très
importantes pour nos territoires
il ya beaucoup d'habitants qu en
prennent conscience et effectivement on
le voit dans les grandes métropoles où
les habitants et qui sont absolument
attentifs à ces évolutions se sont
davantage mobilisés
ils ont porté à leur tête effectivement
des élus écologistes vous ayez joachim
fillot qu'aujourd'hui les verts sont un
temps de prendre une forme d'ascendant
sur le parti socialiste est sûre elle
est fille en tout cas sur la gauche vous
ne voyez pas les choses comme ça à la
lumière de ces résultats
quand même avec des surprises dans les
grandes villes non mais bien sûr on voit
très bien que le mouvement écologiste
dans son sens large du terme prendre
l'ampleur parce qu'une parle qu'ovide
accélérer certaines prises de conscience
également lorsque par exemple on
souhaite renforcer des circuits courts
la qualité d'alimentation mettre du bio
dans les cantines scolaires à 100% bien
effectivement s'il ya une prise de
conscience très forte et le parti dans
le porte bien évidemment puisqu'ils ont
déjà porté depuis plusieurs années je
crois que l'avenir c'est plutôt un
rassemblement au niveau écologique et
sociale je pense que le parti socialiste
a un rôle non négligeable à jouer
d'ailleurs non les socialistes bien sûr
nous avons déjà développé des politiques
pour protéger l'environnement pour
renforcer la transition énergétique
je me souviens des appels à projets qui
avaient été lancées par l'ancien
gouvernement a une voix en tant que
communauté urbaine d'alençon nous avons
répondu à des projets pour qu'on soigne
territoire d'énergie positive par
exemple donc je pense que dans beaucoup
de mouvements politiques
il ya cette prise de conscience mais
livré comme historiquement ce sont les
verts qui ont porté ces problématiques
bien ils sont plutôt effectivement ils
sont heurtés actuellement par par cette
nécessité
alors le premier secrétaire de votre
parti olivier faure s'est dit prêt je
suis ta se ranger derrière le candidat
qui interne aura le bloc social
écologiste
quelle que soit son origine politique en
2022 et vous moi c'est la même chose je
crois que on l'a vu d'ailleurs dans des
grandes villes où des candidats ne vais
pas lui forcément d'expérience politique
locale se sont révélés à travers une
campagne municipale et ont gagné donc je
pense que la présidentielle va va
apporter effectivement peut-être des
surprises
je ne sais pas qui sera candidat pour la
gauche pour la parti socialiste pour les
écologistes est ce qu'on peut se mettre
d'accord sur un candidat avec les mêmes
valeurs sont proches je prends mon cul
mode valeur avec un projet qui
correspond aux victimes en automne et
ses sites et d'aujourd'hui de demain
c'est probable voilà donc ce accepte ça
peut être une possibilité un scrutin
évidemment marqué on le sait par une
abstention record c'est un scrutin
sincère pour vous il est sincère dans la
mesure où les habitants qui sont
déplacés mais effectivement il ya plus
de 60 % d'abstentionnistes il faut
l'analyser
je pense que vous avez des jeunes qui
sont en difficulté qui ont des problèmes
d'insertion mais ils ne vont pas voter
vous avez des familles qui ont été
atteints par la grille à la par la crise
et qui ne croient plus aux politiques
également dont il ya une rupture entre
le politique une certaine population
je crois toutefois absolument qu'on
renforce dans nos pratiques pendant les
nomades nature la démocratie
participative
ils sont davantage associer les
habitants aux décisions de qu'on va
prendre le niveau d'une commune
collectivité d'un territoire ou d'un
département ou d'une région
on le voit bien qu actuellement dans les
démocraties occidentales
le taux de participation est de moins en
moins important et donc il faut qu'on
s'interroge sur la manière dont notre
démocratie doit être plus vivant et
façon à ce que les habitants soit mieux
associé faudra faire de la prévention
faudra faire de la citoyenneté également
dans les écoles dans les collèges dans
les lycées mais c'est vrai que c'est un
grand souci c'est un c'est un défi que
doit relever gestion espérer qu'on
pourra le relever ensemble
merci bon cognac et ma fille au député
ps de l'orne élu maire d'alençon fière
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de la rencontre
en 3 emmanuel macron est un cas là
merkel avec un objectif la relance
européenne et donc convaincre les vingt
cinq autres pays d'adopter le plan à
750 milliards d'euros et puis nous
reviendrons sur l'article du new york
times qui affirme que la russie aurait
versé des primes aux talibans pour tuer
des soldats américains et de l'otan en
afghanistan 23 me en bloc ces
allégations tout comme os ou et les
talibans le même
[Musique]
la crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde le président un
brésilien janet jackson arrow ni la
gravité de la pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaître nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
une trump est vraiment passé à côté du
problème dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences est ce selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine
le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer en soit vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck salle que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on l'a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
quoi construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tous mais en classe pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
20h30 heure de paris soyez les bienvenus
en direct sur rt france emmanuel macron
s'est entretenu cet après midi avec la
chancelière allemande angela merkel les
deux dirigeants souhaitent convaincre un
les pays de l'union européenne d'adopter
un plan de relance économique de l'acno
mission européenne angela merkel espère
que les leaders de l'ue se mettront
d'accord sur le prochain budget lors
d'un sommet prévu les 17 et 18 juillet
prochains à deux jours de la présidence
allemande de l'union européenne le
président français a tenu à rappeler les
enjeux qui joueront au cours des
prochains mois attendre ne rendra pas
les choses plus simples compte tenu de
l'agenda européen ambitieux que devra
porter la présidence allemande et nous
avons aussi évoqué tous ses autres
dossiers le breakbeat et la future
relation avec le royaume uni qui doit
être coopérative mais juste jamais nous
ne pourrons accepter qu être à
l'extérieur de l'union européenne
permettent d'accéder à notre marché sont
respecter nos règles
ce serait l'un vers une europe
souveraine nous aurons aussi à traiter
de l'enjeu du climat vous l'avez rappelé
nous devrons d'ici la fin de l'année
rehausser nos objectifs de réduction
d'émissions pour 2030 et faire en sorte
que les plans de relance européens et
nationaux respecte ses objectifs et à
cet égard il me semble indispensable que
l'argent qu'apportera l'europe aux pays
qui font leur transition écologique soit
strictement conditionné à des
engagements climatiques précis à
commencer par la neutralité carbone 2050
pour en parler nous sommes avec l'autre
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude da
blanche maison
merci d'être avec nous en direct alors
peut-on retenir de cette rencontre entre
angela merkel et emmanuel macron à ce
que des informations ont filtré
la chancelière angela merkel et le
président macron ont en effet envisager
la manière de coordonner les politiques
allemandes et françaises au cours des
six prochains mois puisque comme vous
venez de le dire après demain commence
la présidence allemande du conseil de
l'union européenne
c'est une présidence qui tournent tous
les six mois et c'est très important
quand un pays fondateur de l'union
européenne comme l'allemagne exerce
cette présidence alors évidemment l'un
des points immédiat puisqu'il y aura un
conseil européen les 17 et 18 juillet
prochains
et avec le déplacement physique des
chefs d'état de gouvernement comme
aujourd'hui il y avait un déplacement
physique de monsieur macron à mais ce
verbe on entre donc dans la presse
coronavirus eh bien on attend si
possible un accord sur la proposition
faite par la commission cette
proposition d'un emprunt de 750
milliards d'euros dont 500 seraient
consacrés à des subventions budgétaires
aux états qui ont subi les conséquences
les plus graves
banderas crise du coronavirus et 250 à
des prêts également pour les états qui
ont subi les conséquences les plus
sévères
pendant pendant la crise alors on sait
que ceux ci butent sur les réserves très
forte
l'opposition de quatre états qu'on a
appelée frugaux d'ailleurs je sais pas
très bien pourquoi un journaliste autre
jour les a appelés de saada c'est
peut-être plus justifiée puisque ce sont
quatre et à qui il aurait déjà bénéficié
d'une réduction dans leur contribution
au budget de l'union européenne
c'est un héritage de la réduction
britannique mais qui va cesser avec la
sortie de la grande-bretagne de l'union
européenne le 1er janvier prochain
donc à plus de raison d'accorder une
réduction à ces quatre étapes que sont
les pays bas le danemark
la suède et l'autriche mais ils veulent
conserver cette réduction
cet avantage est évidemment ils
l'utilisent comme un moyen de
négociation pour bouger sur la
proposition de la commission
par ailleurs je pense qu'ils sont assez
aussi à ce qu' il y ait autant de
subventions budgétaires 500 milliards
alors paraît beaucoup la partie prêts
pose moins de problème mais pour la
partie dont la partie subventions ils
veulent qu'il y ait des contreparties
c'est à dire des engagements
d'utilisation très très très stricte par
les états qui en bénéficiaient il va
donc falloir trouver un équilibre parce
que l'italie est déjà dit qu'elle ne
voulait pas être soumises à une tutelle
de bruxelles pour l'utilisation de ces
fonds voilà pour la négociation la plus
immédiate mais hier en effet beaucoup
d'autres sujets qui ont été évoqués par
la chancelière et par le président et y
compris des sujets de politique
internationale
vous avez évoqué en ces réticences des
pays dits frugaux est-ce que avec
justement cette résistance cette
initiative franco allemande at elle des
chances de voir le jour
écoutez oui parce que les pays frugaux
ont une grande déception c'est que leur
chef de file était jusqu'à il ya deux
mois
madame merkel l'allemagne or il se
trouve que après mûre réflexion
l'allemagne a vu que son intérêt bien
compris et est de sauver le marché
unique et par conséquent d'aider les
pays qui étaient les plus affectées par
la crise l essai depuis l'an convaincre
les quatre autres pays avec lesquels
elle était de cette opinion en est en
effet de ne pas engager les dépenses
supplémentaires a à ce titre
alors ça c'est un événement important
parce qu'ils ont perdu leur leader qui
est l'économie la plus puissante de
l'union européenne
et ça les expose beaucoup par ailleurs
les pays bas pays fondateurs aussi de
l'union européenne ont une tradition
européenne à l'origine d'ailleurs il
était beaucoup plus intégrationniste que
la france et voulait tout intégré dans
l'union européenne est aujourd'hui se
retrouve un petit peu un petit peu a
compris à contre-pied il est possible
d'ailleurs qu' on est plus de fil à
retordre avec des pays comme l'autriche
ou comme des pays comme la suède ou le
danemark qui ont adhéré plus récemment à
l'union européenne et pour des raisons
qui tiennent surtout aux avantages
commerciaux qu'ils en retirent alors
angela merkel justement dans ces
conditions à ce que la selon vous au
claude manche maison une occasion de
marquer l'histoire elle qui quitteront
le rappelle le pouvoir à la fin de son
mandat en 2021
oui d'ailleurs vous pouvez vous voyez
vous pouvez vérifier que angela merkel a
actuellement des sondages qui ce qui lui
sont très favorables en allemagne où la
population considère en général qu'elle
a bien géré la crise et puis son image
de mutti merkel comme on dit en
allemagne maman merkel protectrice qui
en est fait plett aux allemands elle a
par ailleurs une voix très importante au
sein des instances européennes
parce qu'elle a beaucoup d'expérience
elle a déjà géré une présidence
allemande et on attend beaucoup de ce
semestre en effet le présidente je pense
aussi qu'elle veut laisser son nom dans
l'histoire dans l'histoire de
l'allemagne mais aussi dans l'histoire
de l'europe avant de quitter la
chancellerie dans un an et demi alors au
menu également des discussions les
négociations post break site la chine
les etats unis mais aussi la russie que
peut-on en attendre
or je pense que tout le monde souhaite
que la négociation du break 6 2 se passe
bien c'est à dire qu'il ya un accord sur
le régime des échanges entre la grande
bretagne ont leur wyoming grande
bretagne et le continent
mais ça n'est pas sûr qu'on y arrive et
monsieur boris johnson ne fait rien pour
qu'on y arrive et
il donne l'impression qu'il se
contenterait d'un break site sans accord
il faut donc s'y préparer et il est
probable que le chancelier le président
la chancelière et le président ont parlé
de cette hypothèse s'agissant de la
russie j'imagine que le président macron
a parlé à la chancelière de son projet
de voyage à moscou pour rencontrer le
président poutine pour parler très
généralement des problèmes de sécurité
en europe mais aussi pour évoquer la
question ukrainienne bien sûr et puis
pour parler de la syrie et de la lubie
libye où il a estimé que certains
progrès étaient possibles dans une
discussion avec la russie
et puis d'autres sujets bien sûr la
turquie puisque la turquie a une
attitude très offensive en libye
offensive est offensante aussi pour la
france puisqu'elle elle s'en est pris à
un navire de la marine française il ya
peu de temps en le menaçant parce que ça
c'est tout simplement parce que ce
navire voulait contrôler que le navire
turc ne transportait pas déjà vous avez
été un embargo sur les armes qui a été
décidé par les par l'onu par ailleurs la
turquie a transporté en libye des
milices pro turc eux qui se battaient
auparavant en syrie donc ça fait quand
même beaucoup pour la turquie
merci beaucoup aux claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
un article du new york times affirme que
la russie aurait versé des primes aux
talibans pour tuer des soldats
américains et de l'otan en afghanistan
les accusation reprise par d'autres
médias qui ont été démenties par moscou
et donc donald trump dit ne pas être au
courant
pour le président américain il s'agit
d'une nouvelle tentative de lui nuire à
quelques mois d'élections
présidentielles
thomas boni les accusations sont
particulièrement graves dans un article
publié le 26 juin le new york times
affirme que la russie aurait offert des
primes à des insurgés en afghanistan
afin qu'ils tuent des soldats américains
une unité russe est particulièrement
visée les etats unis ont conclu il ya
des mois que cette unité russe qui a été
relié à des tentatives d'assassinât et
autres opérations en
up ayant l'intention de déstabiliser
l'occident ou de prendre sa revanche sur
des renégats a secrètement offert des
récompenses pour des attaques réussies
l'an passé des allégations qui repose
exclusivement sur des sources anonymes
pour la plupart issus des services de
renseignement américains ces sources
anonymes souvent désignée par le terme
officials sont cités à 19 reprises dans
l'article sans que l'on puisse savoir si
une même personne ait mentionné
plusieurs fois
au final seuls deux citations sont issus
de personnes clairement identifiés
dmitri peskov porte-parole du kremlin et
zabihullah mujahid un porte-parole des
talibans qui réfute totalement les
allégations des services de
renseignement américains expliquant
notamment que les talibans opèreraient
par leurs propres moyens pour mener
leurs opérations d'assassinats depuis
d'autres médias ont repris en choeur les
mêmes allégations affirmant être en
mesure de confirmer la véracité de cette
affaire peut-être ont-ils eu eux aussi
accès à des témoignages anonymes venant
de sources issues des renseignements ces
mêmes sources qui indiquent que le
président trump elle est au courant de
cette affaire
le principal intéressé lui s'en défend
personne ne m'a briefé ou ne m'a parlé
le vice président mike pence ou le
directeur de cabinet marc meadows à
propos des soi-disant attaques contre
nos troupes en afghanistan par les
russes comme cela a été rapporté par une
source anonyme du new york times fait qu
news tout le monde le dément et il n'y a
pas eu beaucoup d' attaques contre nous
donald trump voit dans ces allégations
une énième volonté de lui nuire à
quelques mois de la présidentielle
américaine d'ailleurs les démocrates
joe biden en tête se sont rués sur cette
affaire pour accuser une nouvelle fois
le chef d'état américain de collusion
avec la russie et c'est vrai que le
timing de ces allégations a de quoi
interroger alors que washington a signé
en février dernier un accord historique
avec les talibans qui acte le retrait de
ses troupes d'afghanistan
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis plymouth au royaume uni avec
patrick henning scène
expert en relations internationales
fondateur du site toualy one century ou
ailleurs c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soit bonsoir patrick kane
une scène merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors ce sont
évidemment des accusations très graves
et qui repose exclusivement sur des
sources anonymes pour la plupart issus
des services de renseignement américains
pourtant elles ont été reprises dans de
nombreux médias
ce n'est pas la première fois
c'est une tradition à washington les
agences de renseignement d'un des
informations à des journées importants
comme le muretain sous le washington
post
tes sources anonymes souci n'est pas
tribu des événements accuse quantité en
l'occurrence c'est la russie l'enquète
sur müller et processus de destitution
était fondée sur les mêmes stratégies
kokmen au sein de l'association
trump la même s'il est la tradition
environ 30 ans donald trump a déjà bien
connu cela et je pense que beaucoup de
l'information des services de
renseignement à la maison blanche
évoquer des sujets il doit savoir que
ces accusations sont présentés par les
services de renseignement et pourrait qu
pas être fondées en l'occurrence il ya
des implications géopolitiques forme
tout d'abord cela dit souad et donald
trump continuer le processus de détente
avec la russie par exemple les nouveaux
traités d'armé renégociation des traités
nucléaires entre les deux pays pourrait
être interrompu pour y avoir un
accroissement des tensions
et cela également un impact sur le
processus électoral et avec notamment
par exemple les militaires cardona
tremplin devoir choisir la russie où
l'armée est pourtant essayé de se
présenter comme président promu terre
donc c'est une
c'est un sujet d'actualité conçu pour
acculer une fois de plus donald trump
comme l'autre est un sujet d'actualité
comme par exemple tout ce qui tournait
autour des ruches gates comme de ce
facteur guère apprécié la russie
redevient le fantôme l'épouvantail car
remplit un vide levée de la numéro un
est de toute évidence cette histoire est
très légère qui est bien et ce soin à
l'efo thèmes qui sont cachés derrière
qui va continuer l'occupation en
afghanistan renforcer l'otan la russie
voudrait tel look et mettre en place des
politiques il maintiendrait la présence
des etats-unis en afghanistan c'est
vraiment contre intuitif et pour moi
c'est surtout de la fiction donc si on
vous suit bien à qui profiterait ces
accusations il ya plusieurs quand vous
l'avez expliqué les pros les contre la
maintient en afghanistan il ya aussi en
tout cas ça c'est donald trump qu'il dit
l'opposition parce que il faut le
rappeler est évidemment le timing tombe
voilà un moment pas aux panneaux dans à
quelques mois de la présidentielle
américaine avoir l esprit le contexte et
le prix de ce les histoires avec la v6
floués
c'est d'actualité en quelques sortes les
états unis sont encouragés à adopter une
posture agressive envers la russie
les médias américains se livrent à ce
genre d'opération a régulièrement
les services de renseignement un produit
ce qu'est l'histoire des sujets liés aux
ajustements à la russie c'est vrai
également à la télévision et on les
retrouve dans tous les grands groupes
médiatiques américain il y a à la cia il
ya le conseil de sécurité nationale qui
a construit toute une histoire plus
concernant le gel de transferts d'armes
vers l'ukraine et asseyez de déclencher
justement cette destitution
donc cela ne devrait surprendre personne
mais il s'agit de couvrir un thème plus
général
l'année dernière on a déclassifié
certains documents sur l'afghanistan qui
montrait que sept huit ou neuf ans
auparavant nous communistes avaient déjà
que la guerre en afghanistan était un
échec il devrait se retirer
ce n'était pas ça n'a pas été une
histoire le washington post l'a évoqué
l'année dernière mais c'est très
important au vu du nombre d'années que
les états unis ont passé en afghanistan
avec le coup militaire et humains ainsi
qu'ils communiquent que cela représente
résiste l'occupation et effectivement
c'est une résistance comme on pourrait
trouver dans n'importe quel pays
bombardier est occupée mais on essaie de
détourner l'opinion de ceux là et on
parle maintenant d'organisations
terroristes
cela fleure certaines portions de
l'auditoire américain mais ce sont elles
les etats-unis ont créé la situation
avec l'opération cyclone ce temps dans
les années 1980 afin de chasser la
russie de la région et le lou jatteau
s'est rapidement transformé est devenue
ces mouvements des talibans et de l'al
qaïda c'est vraiment j'ai déroulé au
niveau historique
c'est là à douvres
faire les gros titres mais c'est le
travail des propagandistes il essaye de
créer de nouvelles histoires afin de
cacher de détourner l'attention de deux
thèmes beaucoup plus fondamentaux sur le
long terme
merci beaucoup patrick hansen d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france et
de nous avons apporté votre opinion sur
ce sujet merci à vous au mali est
présent le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
prolonge d'un an la mission des casques
bleus la mission multi dimensionnelle
intégré des nations unies pour la
stabilisation mali la minus ma restera
donc sur le terrain jusqu'en juin 2021
depuis janvier 2000 20 580 civils ont
trouvé la mort souvent à cause de
conflit inter communautaire une année
supplémentaire donc lors de laquelle les
casques bleus renforceront leur
coopération avec les forces conjointes
du g5 sel et pour clément yao
journaliste et directeur de la
publication du magazine l'afrique
aujourd'hui c'est une bonne chose que
les casques bleus restent sains en plus
haut mais de la prolongation c'est une
issue inévitable vu que le problème du
mali demeure intacte il n'a pratiquement
pas changé
et puisque les forces loyalistes sont
toujours l'action sur le terrain et en
dépit la présence de trois forces
militaires notamment la milice marque le
g5 sahel et les phrases banales france
barkan alors et en sort plus de cela il
ya aussi haut niveau donc des autorités
politiques à une espèce de contestation
populaire qui a eu lieu il ya quelques
jours de cela tout se mélange la paix la
sécurité et aussi d'un stabilité de ce
pays
donc je pense que la provocation était
tout à fait normal et iv nécessaire
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat emmanuel macron
à donner des réponses aux propositions
et a notamment promis d'injecter 15
milliards d'euros supplémentaires pour
accélérer la transition écologique
crinon viendront sur la décision prise
par le groupe l'oréal de retirer les
mots blanc blanchi sans éclair de tous
les produits dans un contexte tendu de
manifestations racistes aux quatre coins
du monde
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité mais idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent
là elle en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on est une gauche plus
extrêmes
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview vous parlez de
résilience
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
gata ce trop fine il ya un tournant mais
on re se remet à vivre mais dans une
autre direction c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité que pour
sauver des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais une décision après semblable
pour vous ça dépend quelle valeur on
attribue à la mort et à la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie revient
feu mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral un débat éthique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je suis
finissent par renoncer au soir vous avez
proposé deux posters en falck faire que
ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
ça fait plus d'une vingtaine d'années
qui a un certain nombre d'événements
inattendus qui bouleverse cet ordre
mondial on essaie le faire perdurer mais
on est à la fin d'un modèle qui était le
tout misé sur la dette
tu as la tête et la relance par la dette
ou par la création monétaire
c'est quelque chose qui a fonctionné
systématiquement on l'a dit des milliers
de fois c'est pas en imprimant des
billets que vous relancer une économie
si on essaie autant de relancer la
croissance économique s'est peu
fondamentalement on sait on sait pas
faire ce en passant c'est connu je peux
pas continuer à diffuser des chiffres
qui sont absolument faux simplement
parce que ça arrange monsieur trump à ce
moment là
le fait que nous avons eu ce problème de
la pandémie qui a été mondiale va amener
d'autres façons de faire des affaires et
les choses vont beaucoup se concentrer
sur l'humain et sur l'environnement
partout en afrique les présidents
prennent conscience qu'il faut vraiment
se réindustrialiser et là je pense que
l'aco vie va permettre à cette
réinitialisation cela ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne doit plus commercer mais
commercer de manière différents qui
permettent à tout un chacun d'avoir un
travail de dessin un salaire décent
je pense que le salaire qui permet de
vivre ça c'est le plus important
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
la crise du corona virus s'aggrave en
amérique latine situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde le président un
brésilien janet jackson arrow ni la
gravité de la pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
il
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petits échos positifs a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
du zèle à la télévision
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview en pleine crise
du corona virus après avoir constaté
l'incapacité de l'union européenne à
manifester la moindre solidarité envers
des etam l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise la montée
en puissance de la chine dans le
commerce mondial a évidemment réduit le
poids de l'euro il faut y ajouter la
fragmentation de la zone et son
incapacité à parler d'une seule voix la
rend beaucoup moins attractif il est
évident que le projet politique d'une
véritable union est mort entre des
membres trop différent et trop non la
vraie question est de savoir si le
président français va vouloir et pouvoir
rebondir et comment les choix sont
multiples mais tout le problème va être
bien choisi
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre
direct sur arte france pour cette
deuxième heure d'émission
il est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 29 juin
une page se tourne celle de la centrale
de fessenheim l'arrêt du réacteur 2 a
débuté cet après-midi plutôt prévu au
lendemain d'élections municipales
triomphante pour les verts emmanuel
macron lui a reçu à l'elysée les 150
membres de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat l'oréal la décision du groupe
de retirer les mots blanc blanchi sans
éclair de tous ces produits n'en finit
pas de faire couler de l'encré un appel
au boycott du leader mondial des
cosmétiques a été lancé sur les réseaux
sociaux
une décision qui intervient à la suite
des manifestations anti raciste aux
quatre coins du monde et alors que les
marques sont sous pression alors sept
ponts comme le dénonce url à des
revendications racialiste qui divise les
hommes en fonction de leur couleur
elles se compteraient au contraire une
bonne stratégie pour combattre le
racisme ce sera l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir
[Musique]
en pologne le second tour de la
présidentielle prévue le 12 juillet
opposera le président sortant
duda à rafal traçage cofsky le maire de
varsovie un conservateur face à un
libéral les deux candidats sont donnés
au coude à coude avec près de 10 % des
polonais indécis selon un dernier
sondage
au brésil les crises sanitaires accélère
le kobe 19 a fait déjà plus de cinquante
sept mille morts les manifestations
contre la gestion de la pandémie par
jaillir au bol sonar au se multiplient
une réprobation qui s'amplifie à mesure
que le président minimise le virus
[Musique]
au lendemain de la vague verte aux
municipales emmanuel macron a donc reçu
les 150 membres de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat à la mi journée
toutes les propositions faites ont été
acceptées par le président hormis trois
d'entre elles
le résumé avec emilie gogh h un
président mise au défi à la suite du
triomphe des verts aux municipales après
sa rencontre avec les membres de la
convention pour le climat ce matin
emmanuel macron a annoncé qu'il adhérait
à presque toutes les propositions
j'irai au bout de ce contrat moral qui
nous lie en transmettant effectivement
la totalité de vos propositions à
l'exception de trois d'entre elles les
trois joker dont nous avions parlé en
janvier sur 149 sur lesquels justement
je verrai parmi les initiatives rejetée
par le président la taxe de 4 % sur les
dividendes
d'après emmanuel macron elle risquerait
de décourager d'investissement écartée
également la limitation à 110 km/heure
de la vitesse sur les autoroutes
enfin le président n'a pas retenu la
proposition de réécriture du préambule
de la constitution
les membres de la convention souhaitait
faire prévaloir la préservation de
l'environnement sur les autres principes
fondamentaux de la république
pour le reste des propositions emmanuel
macron s'est engagé à les transmettre au
gouvernement au parlement ou encore à
les soumettre au référendum
autre annonce celle d'une enveloppe de
15 milliards d'euros supplémentaires sur
deux ans pour la conversion écologique
l'état prendra toute sa part c'est
pourquoi dès le plan de relance que nous
sommes en train de préparer 15 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires sur deux ans
seront injectés dans la conversion
écologique de notre économie
des annonces fortes alors que les verts
sont les grands vainqueurs des
municipales
un triomphe qui contraste avec la
déroute de la république en marche qui
n'a remporté aucune grande ville à
l'exception du havre avec la réélection
d'edouard philippe toutefois
non-encartés lrm ont pour en parler nous
sommes avec françois michel lambert
député de là
10ème circonscription des bouches du
rhône group liberté et territoires
bonsoir françois michel lambert merci
d'être avec nous en direct ce soir sur
rtl france pour vous à skis emmanuel
macron donne des réponses fortes
aujourd'hui aux propositions des 150
membres de la convention citoyenne
je pense que le problème de emmanuel
macron c'est un problème de ne pas avoir
saisi ce que c'est que l'écologie c'est
une forme de pensée aborder le monde
différemment aborder le monde par
rapport à ce que nous sommes nous sommes
finalement que matière dans une dans un
univers dense sur cette terre et non pas
à côté dans des calculs économiques dans
des calculs de relations de business
d'ailleurs il a bien dit le 4 % je le
repousse le 110 km heure je le prends
pas emmanuel macron c'était le médecin
qui vous a soigné les jambes ou plutôt
fracassé la jambe gauche puis la jambe
droite
il essaye de les soigner tant bien que
mal l'écologie c'est un autre médecin
qu'il nous faut c'est celui qui pense
tout le corps qui pense au niveau de
comment nous comportons on peut pas
avoir une personne qui ne sait s'occuper
que de fractures aux jambes pour
s'occuper de notre problème global qui
est tout notre corps est donc emmanuel
macron ne saura toujours à côté de la
plaque sur l'écologie donc moi je n'ai
aucune intention de me croire en quoi
que ce soit par rapport à ce qu'il va
mettre en oeuvre justement on en
reparlera après on va pas les aborder là
parce qu'on va en parler en détail les
municipales bon c'est un signal à cette
convention 15 milliards d'euros pour la
transition écologique la proche pour lui
aussi de la présidentielle vous pensez
qu'il ne va pas justement changer son
fusil d'épaulé alors qu'il voit après
ces élections les rebelles et
municipales que les français ont à coeur
la question de l'écologie les questions
de l'écologie on confond toujours la
problématique environnementale
le problème évidemment au contraire moi
j'ai engagé depuis trente ans en
écologie mais c'est une façon d'aborder
notre société de la solidarité
peut-être ce qu'on appelle la low tech a
comparé à son idée lui la start up
nation où toute la technologie va nous
sauver on a bien vu que ce sont plutôt
des hommes et des femmes qui nous ont
sauvés du coc vide que une application
qui est tombé en rade qui s'appelle stop
qu'ovide on a bien vu
que c'est les régions c'est la proximité
c'est la solidarité que les grandes le
grand capital qui lui n'a apporté que
quelques jets l'hydraulique et parfois
des masques mais pas l'organisation sur
le terrain c'est les premiers de corvée
et pas les premiers de cordée qui sont
la vraie résilience de notre monde c'est
ce sont les maires locaux
c'est parce cette verticalité
jupitérienne là emmanuel macron bref il
comprend pas et il ne peut pas c'est
comment vous expliquez est il ce n'est
pas dans sa capacité par rapport à ce
qu'il a développé je respecte parce
qu'il a développée au cours de son
histoire et qui riche de comprendre que
c'est un autre format de monde que l'on
pourrait rapporter à ce qu'a été
l'humanité depuis la nuit des temps et
qui si des structures et au xxème siècle
où il est resté bloqué dans la frange de
l'humanité qui est le 20e siècle et non
dans ce cas était l'humanité depuis
qu'elle et humanité alors vous restez
avec nous s'il vous plaît françois
michel lambert nous allons justement
évoquer ces municipales 1 strasbourg on
a vu les images longuement bordeaux lyon
les verts ont remporté des villes
symboliques en france
illustration à lyon où il signe un
doublé avec la mairie et la métropole
après 19 ans de règne de gérard collomb
valentin carpentier avec des images luis
carballo
c'est en vainqueur que grigori douce et
s'est présenté devant ses militants
leurs représentants d'europe écologie
les verts a largement été élu maire de
lyon grâce à son alliance avec le ps
la france a soumises et le parti
communiste un moment historique pour le
nouvel élu
lyon avait rendez vous avec l'histoire
la voici lyon est au rendez vous
nous sommes rendez vous lyon a choisi
l'écologie alors on peut dire lyon et
fait de cette étoffe dont sont hissés
les rêves malgré 62 % abstention l'élu
écologiste a devancé le camp du maire
sortant gérard collomb qui devra se
contenter d'un poste de simple
conseiller municipal un tournant pour la
troisième ville de france qui tourne une
page longue de 19 années de règne
son nouveau maire a bien l'intention
d'en faire une référence lyon va devenir
une référence et nous ne sommes pas
seuls dans cette aventure
grenoble est aussi elle aussi
écologistes ce soir tout comme bordeaux
strasbourg marseille et bien d'autres
villes encore seul ombre au tableau une
interruption de la soirée par des
militants pour l'hébergement qui ont
demandé une prolongation de la trêve
hivernale jusqu'en mars 2021
pas de quoi gâcher la fête pour un des
nouveaux représentants de la vague verte
en france et françois michel lambert qui
est toujours avec nous vous vous
attendiez à un tel succès des verts
notamment dans les grandes villes
françaises
or c'est les verts et c'est l'écologie
en général un qui réussit alors
peut-être pas un tel sujet soyons
honnête par contre ce que l'on ressent
d'abord ça fait un moment que le vrai
nouveau monde c'est justement celui qui
est inscrit à notre approche un autre
logiciel c'est ce que j'ai expliqué tout
à l'heure et il a émergé beaucoup plus
vite
après cette crise du coc vide la crise
que nous avons subie bata seul coup tout
le monde s'est rendu compte il nous faut
on a pu l'alimentation on n'a plus les
médicaments
on nous parle et c'est emmanuel macron
je souhaite que vous fassiez vos
entreprises que vous gagnez des millions
que vous puissiez avoir des ferrari
alors qu'en vérité ce sont des gens qui
utilisent le métro quand ils
fonctionnent et qui nous ont permis de
survivre de survivre et donc que autre
chose à se mettre en oeuvre et c'est
bien là proche des écologistes qui
certes ne va pas flamber ne va pas vous
dire demain vous aurez une belle ferrari
où vous irez en vacances tous les ans
voire trois fois par an aux seychelles
aux maldives et je ne sais ils vous
disent non vous aurez peut-être pas tout
ça mais vous aurez une vie riche riche
de solidarité de liens avec les autres
et mais aussi de lien est ce que nous
sommes
parce que les hommes nous sommes une
partie de cette vie qui est sur la terre
nous ne sommes pas à côté de la vie donc
nous devons retrouver un équilibre avec
ne vous décrivez est ce que ce sont les
verts les écologistes qui ont ce
monopole là on peut être socialiste on
peut être les républicains et avoir ce
genre d'idée que vous êtes en train de
développer un jeu on peut être avec des
valeurs approchante et ceux qui sont les
plus proches sont évidemment les valeurs
progressistes qui se situent
essentiellement à gauche il ya aussi un
progressisme de droite je ne le nie pas
mais les républicains qui sont sur
d'autres approches plus
d'entrepreneuriat plus d'individualisme
plus de réussite personnelle et non des
approches collectives comment voulez
vous qu'ils comprennent ce sens de du
lien ensemble comment voulez vous qu'ils
mettent qu'il ralentisse décroissance
d'entreprise qui nous détruisent pour
permettre à chacun de pouvoir suivre et
ne pas détruire la planète c'est pas
dans leurs logiciels
cc c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre le
transformation du monde elle se fera par
une approche qui nous remet en lien avec
ce que nous sommes nous ne sommes pas
des extraterrestres cette planète nous
sommes une partie prenante de la vie sur
cette terre et nous devons avoir des
logiciels décembre de pensée de
solidarité comme il en existe dans la
nature entre animaux de différentes
espèces parfois qu'ils arrivent à
survivre dans des espaces très
contraignant au milieu des déserts au
fin fond des océans
parce qu'ils savent s'entraider et non
s'entretuer pour quelqu'un qui soit plus
gros que les autres mais quand il est
plus gros que les autres il a tué tout
le monde ébahi meurent parce qu'il est
dans un environnement hostile
et bien c'est ça la vie sur la terre et
c'est ça l'humanité qu'elle doit
construire demain sinon nous risquons
effectivement un effondrement de
l'humanité et je rappelle c'est ce que
dit edouard philippe
donc je lui demanderais d'être en phase
avec ses propres propos et de
complètement changer son logiciel aussi
s'il peut
françois michel lambert ne va pas
entamer ici un débat sur le nucléaire
est une petite question parce que
c'était l'un des événements aussi
écologique de la journée une page se
tourne à la fermeture depuis le temps
qu'on en parle de la centrale de
fessenheim une bonne chose pour vous
enfin lui c'est une bonne chose parce
que la france est le pays avec un taux
de nucléaire est extrêmement élevé
l'hyper technologie qui va nous sauver
sauf qu'on a vu des catastrophes
tchernobyl fukushima qu'on n'est pas
passé loin nous mêmes de catastrophes
qu'on est devant peut-être aussi un
black out parce que le coc vide à
retarder dé maintenance de centrales et
donc peut-être qu'à l'hiver prochain
voir l'hiver d'après les centrales ne
seront pas disponibles et trompe
peut-être dans l'hyper technologie on en
revient toujours la même chose on se
coupe d'une réalité l'énergie elle est
partie prenante de cette terre elle est
partie prenante de notre vie sur la
terre c'est pas l'hyper technologie mais
c'est plutôt l'accompagnement
l'accompagnement que les énergies
renouvelables le solaire l'éolien la
biomasse mais aussi de ne pas
surconsommer
donc c'est bien des approches
écologistes que nous devons avoir et non
des approches technologiques que peuvent
être le nucléaire la réalité elle est là
et je crains que même la france ou en
difficulté en termes d'approvisionnement
énergétique à cause d'un petit virus qui
aura retardé pendant deux ou trois mois
l'entretien de nos centrales nucléaires
et par voie de d'effet domino à l'hiver
prochain et divers suivant nous n'aurons
pas assez de puissance nucléaire parce
qu'on a tous fondé sur une technologie
75% de l'électricité française voilà
voilà c'est ça que nous devons
complètement changé sans parler des
risques d'accident malheureusement on
l'a vu et malheureusement d'autres
arriveront sur cette planète j'espère
pas en france d'ailleurs
on peut le craindre parce que bon nous
restons le pays avec le plus de
réacteurs au monde
rapporté au nombre d'habitants merci
les nombreuses manifestations anti
racistes à travers le monde met la
pression sur les entreprises
illustration l'oréal a ainsi annoncé
dans un communiqué qu'elle ne vendrait
plus les effets blanchissant ses
produits pour la peau les détails en
images
[Musique]
oh
beaucoup
vous
[Musique]
l oréal qui enlève donc le mot blonde
une certaine gamme de ses produits c'est
la polémique qui a enflammé les réseaux
sociaux ce week-end alors va-t-on trop
loin cette on a des revendications
communautaires qui vont plutôt vers la
division que vous voyez est relativement
ou au contraire est-ce une bonne
décision de lutte contre le racisme
c'est l'objet de notre face à face pour
en débattre nous sommes avec fatima
benomar militante fondatrice du
collectif féministe les effrontés
bonsoir fatima benomar merci d'être avec
nous pour en débattre thaïs militante du
mouvement politique génération
identitaire bonsoir mademoiselle merci
d'être avec nous également
la marque de cosmétiques donc très
célèbre qui supprime les mots blanc
clair blanchissement blanchissant de ces
produits on va commencer par vous thaïs
est ce que ça vous choque vous faites
partie des gens qui ont été voilà prêt
choqué ce week end
par cette décision le real paris a fait
le choix de la soumission idéologique
aux militants anti blancs d'oeufs
blackie amateurs après c'est ce choix de
l'acheter finalement s'est soldée par un
échec cuisant de deux par deux par deux
côtés c'est à dire que le premier cela a
engendré un appel au boycott massif sur
les réseaux sociaux que des dizaines de
milliers d'internautes ont suivi
d'autre part la validation politique
qu'il recherchait auprès des militants
anti blanc de blacklight matters n'a pas
fonctionné il nourrit côté que du mépris
et j'oserais dire encore encore pire
vous avez des militants qui disait que
ce n'était pas assez que ces produits
auraient dû être retiré de la vente et
que l'oréal devait cesser toute
commercialisation de ses produits
je pense notamment à rokhaya diallo qui
l'avait qu'il avait demandé sur twitter
alors fatima benomar effectivement ça
créé un tollé
ce week-end avec un boycott notamment
des produits vous comprenez cette
réaction ou c'est un faux débat pour
vous et c'est une très bonne décision
qu'a prise au l'oréal ben pour moi c'est
une décision en demi teinte
je veux dire c'est à dire que l'oréal
elle supprime les mots blanc et
blanchissement mais elle va maintenir en
vente a priori la vente de ses
cosmétiques et qui vont éclaircir les
poëles fait de l'argent sans milliers ça
marche et 2 milliards de dollars en inde
en jamaïque aux états unis donc c'est un
coup de com qui retire les mois mais qui
ne retire pas des produits ultra toxique
un du marché
le blanchiment si une technique de
dépigmentation avec des produits
chimiques qui est très répandue en
afrique ou en asie parce que la
blancheur ce sont des canaux de des
canons de beauté très imposé même en
france d'ailleurs à la camorra disait
qu' il ya d'un directeur artistique lui
avais dit qu elle pourrait toucher plus
de personnes si elles s'éclaircissait la
peau on sait que ce sont des pratiques
photoshop quand il ya des mannequins
noirs etc et donc non seulement c'est un
problème d'identité c'est à dire que ces
femmes sont incités dès le plus jeune
âge à détester leur apparence et le fait
d'être noir mais c'est un sujet aussi de
santé publique parce que ces produits
sont hyper toxiques et provoque des
cancers etc
il ya des pays comme le rwanda le
sénégal le ghana qui les interdisent
même si du coup ils vont finir dans le
marché au noir
donc moi je suis plutôt un soutien à des
collectifs de jeunes femmes comme
esprits des bennes ou mieux le coup
qu'on sénégal qui au contraire valorise
les femmes noires pour ne pas avoir
honte de leur apparence et j'espère que
ces mobilisations vont changer les
pratiques du monde cosmétiques de même
pas seulement que sur s'assure aussi la
minceur exagéré et c'est dans le monde
du mannequinat par exemple enfin tout ce
qui touche l'apparence des femmes ela
s'est aggravée quand ce sont des femmes
racisées c'est à dire que il y aura
toujours ses produits sur la vente qui
leur font passer le message que leur
peau noire n'est pas belle ou désirable
en tant que tel thaïs d'une certaine
manière on vous est-ce que l'oréal a agi
sous le coup de la pression en voulant
comme le dit fatima benomar faire une
forme de deux coupes commun dans un
contexte évidemment que l'on s'est tendu
par les manifestations notamment aux
états unis
c'est tout simplement cédé à la pression
et s'offrir un coup de communication où
elle a réfléchi peut-être sa stratégie
cette marque c'était la pression oui et
c'est une soumission idéologique c'est
se soumettre à ses militants anti blanc
de la crise matters à leurs
revendications
mais j'ai envie de dire quelle est la
prochaine étape
on supprime le mot blanc du dictionnaire
on supprime les publicités pour
dentifrice qui parle de blanchir les
dents
enfin vous voyez qu on est quand même
dans une une dynamique complètement
grotesque qui est qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas normal ça veut dire quoi pour
vous il ya une forme je caricature
peut-être votre propos mais allons
jusqu'au bout c'est une forme de presque
de racisme anti blanc pour vous thaïs
oui complètement le racisme anti blanc
voilà c'est nous nous faire qu'on fasse
comprendre blanc qu'ils ne sont qu ils
ne sont qu ils sont qu'il y en a trop
qu'ils sont trop nombreux
qu'on l'ait on les efface voilà on est
on efface la simple mention de leur
couleur de peau
le racisme anti blanc après au delà de
ça c'est quand même un phénomène qui est
très répandue qui touche le plus le plus
de monde qui est le plus la haine la
plus violente dans son expression qui
est la plus la plus massive
d'ailleurs c'est un racisme c'est une
haine qu'on a pu quantifier puisque deux
chercheurs de l'ined avait effectué une
une enquête en 2016 qui révélait que 10
millions de français avaient déjà été
confronté au racisme anti blanc et et
voilà fatima benomar vous n'avez pas le
sentiment justement que c'est peut-être
voilà une action parce que la drôme on
précise que l'oréal n'est pas la seule
marque il ya plusieurs marques qui
suivent le pas voilà qui réfléchissent
oncle ben et cetera changer leur chose
d'ailleurs une une marque de dentifrice
justement vous en parliez il ya vraiment
une pression est ce que c'est la bonne
méthode et est ce que quand même vous
vous êtes d'accord avec les propos de
tennis ça peut voilà aussi suggéré un
racisme anti blanc ou pas du tout selon
vous c'est étrange de parler de racisme
anti blanc parce qu'on demandait à des
femmes noires de se blanchir même juste
en train de revenir sur sa sur la base
du canon de beauté qui mettrait une
hiérarchie dans les beautés et où les
calmants de beauté ce serait
éclaircisse donc comment peut-on se
plaindre qu on effacerait ou en
stigmatiserait les femmes blanches alors
qu'on demande est en fait c'était une
réaction au fait de demander à des
femmes noires de rentrer plus dans les
codes physique des femmes blanches
donc je trouve ça très étrange comme
retournement de deux situations et par
rapport est pas un il faut bien
comprendre qu'on héritiers de société ou
se sont ou le sexe et la race la
construction de la race qu'on
fonctionner comme des systèmes de
marquage arbitraire pour justement
construire des réalités archi où on a
considéré que les blancs étaient
supérieurs au noir les hommes étaient
supérieurs aux femmes et c'est ça qui a
permis à la fois l' esclavage les
patriarcats le la colonisation et c'est
ce qui a permis en fait qu'aujourd'hui
on soit héritier d'un système on
retrouve pour objectiver les choses tout
en bas de l'échelle sociale c'est à dire
des personnes qui vont être les plus
dévalorisé on l'a vu pendant la crise
sanitaire c'était les femmes les
personnes racisées qui s'occupait du
nettoyage de nos rues de nos gars de
toilette etc
au plus bas de l'échelle et ce sont bien
elles qui sont confrontés aux
discriminations à l embauche
au travail etc donc c'est bien ce
système qu'on est en train de dénoncer
et en fait à chaque fois comme il ya eu
le mouvement mis tous très vite s'est
posé le débat en ces termes est ce qu'on
va trop loin
est-ce que ça va perturber toute la
société de poser la question de la
domination masculine et du patriarcat et
là il se passe un peu la même chose du
moment que la question du racisme est au
centre du débat tout public
tout de suite on met des barrières à ce
débat et on se dit est ce que déjà on va
trop loin
non je pense qu'il faut tout simplement
comprendre ce débat il ya quand même le
défenseur des droits jacques toubon qui
a produit un très bon travail de
synthèse qui est objective en fait qui
montre des enquêtes et des statistiques
sur la réalité des violences racistes
qui est le point aveugle et silencieux
sur les discriminations ethno racial et
si sûr c'est qu'il faut se baser tout
simplement pour avancer vers une société
égalitaire alors en tout cas ça a fait
réagir jusqu'à la sphère politique ce
week-end si on propose d'écouter ce
tweet de fini
affiné le groupe l'oréal a décidé de
retirer les mots blanc blanchissant
claire de tous ses produits destinés à
uniformiser la peau indiqué le géant
français dans un communiqué marketing
racialiste aujourd'hui si ce fleuron
français fait peser sur ses clients la
honte de leur couleur de peau au nom de
cette idéologie délirante
je demande à tous les gaulois
réfractaires d'arrêter l'oréal à leur
taille et vous vous allez arrêter
l'oréal peut-être quand vous l'utilisez
pas cela dit mais ça vous ferait en tout
cas de ne pas l'acheter même si un
produit vous plaisait oui j'avais
d'ailleurs est posté une vidéo qui a ses
tournées notamment sur twitter où je
t'ai de manière assez symbolique
l'unique produits l'oréal finalement que
je possède et chez moi non clairement je
ne souhaite pas rentrer dans ce jeu je
rejette
je rejette cette volonté cette cette
lâcheté de la part de l'oréal
je n'achèterai clarens plus reproduits
fatima benomar sur ses propos de
philippe de villiers ya également marine
le pen un jury que vous êtes
complètement quand les idées de marine
le pen mais voilà qui explique que ça ne
fait que diviser que ça engendre de la
violence plutôt que de l'apaisement ce
que ça vous lui accordez effectivement
voilà un petit bénéfice du doute est ce
que vous n'avez pas l'impression que ce
débat divise plus qu'il rassemble et
qu'il apaise en tout cas en fait dès
qu'on résiste et qu'on veut changer le
système il y à ce procès de la division
et du coup les personnes qui dénonçaient
des violences systémique de la
discrimination de la stigmatisation et
serra vont être incités à aller vers le
statu quo donc très vite dès qu'on
commence à nous pas taper sur les doigts
mais arrêtez de parler de mitsou vous
êtes en train de dresser les femmes
contre les hommes du concubin on
intériorise un peu une sorte de
culpabilité dit revenons statu quo et là
c'est la même chose qui est au centre
des débats c'est la question raciale
je pense que ça va faire mal dans les
sociétés qui ont un peu mis de côté ce
débat là c'est sûr que ça va se faire
dans un peu de douleur mais
je pense vraiment que c'est une
crispation assez française par exemple
moi je suis triste cinéphiles et aux
états unis
il y a un nombre énorme de films qui
traitent de la question de la guerre du
vietnam
c'est quelque chose qui à irriguer toute
la société suite au tout le mouvement de
jeunes qui a contesté à la haye les
colonies et la guerre du vietnam en
france quand on a fait un débat sur la
question de la guerre d'algérie c'est à
dire avec le film les indigènes tout de
suite c'était d'infini nombre de
plateaux télé à la la mais est ce qu'on
n'est pas en train de faire pénitence et
de vouloir voir notre passé en face et
du cou ça divise
je pense que au contraire ce qu'il faut
c'est voir son histoire dans les yeux
n'est plus là rentrer partielle et
partiale et accepter ces débats et faire
en sorte de pouvoir avancer ensemble
mais ce n'est pas en éludant les
questions parce que bah ça risque de
créer du débat et la division elle vient
plutôt des problèmes qui sont mis de
côté que du moment où on les met sur la
place publique
donc je pense qu'il faut pas avoir peur
de ce débat et ne pas se contenter du
statu quo merci en tout cas à toutes les
deux fatima benomar thaïs d'avoir été
avec nous pour débattre
en direct sur rt france merci dans
quelques instants rester avec nous
partirons en pologne le président
sortant en 12 ans arrivent largement en
tête de l'élection après le premier tour
il devance le maire de varsovie de plus
de 10 points puis direction brésil où le
comique 19 continue à faire des ravages
les manifestations contre jaillir balso
narrow commencé se poursuivent sur toile
dos
[Musique]
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie
trône ici malgré la polémique mondiale
sur l'efficacité de cette combinaison de
la ligue arabe
nous avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les deux types euros qui
vient à manquer les must ne commence à
baisser au sénégal la chloroquine de
maillage analysé pendant des décennies
et des décennies
ça pourrait faire sourire les sénégalais
quand j'entendais il n'y a pas de signes
qui m'est rendu
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france les polonais appelé hier aux
urnes pour le premier tour de la
présidentielle le second aura lieu le 12
juillet le président sortant andré genou
d'affront tra le maire de varsovie
rafale travco ski un second tour qui
selon les observateurs pourraient
s'annoncer serré cyrielle bruit vers un
second tour au coude à coude
c'est ce qui semble attendre les
candidats à la présidentielle en pologne
le 12 juillet prochain
ce dimanche les polonais ont choisi
d'apporter majoritairement leur soutien
au président sortant avec près de 42%
des votes selon un sondage ipsos duda
prend une avance sur son adversaire
de quoi réjouir le chef de l'état qui
n'en oublie pas pour autant les enjeux
de cette élection sans entente avec la
société avait d'énormes attentes pour
améliorer la situation pour améliorer le
train de vie des gens et après cinq ans
bien plus d'électeurs votent pour moi
qu'à l'époque lors du premier tour de la
présidentielle
je vous en remercie de tout coeur merci
l'avenir c'est la famille l'avenir c'est
la sécurité
l'avenir c'est le travail l'avenir ce
sont les investissements l'avenir c'est
la dignité
je n'ai aucun doute que c'est ce dont la
pologne et besoin pour les prochaines
années
face à lui rafal traces cos qui ne
s'avouent pas vaincus le maire de
varsovie sort de ce premier tour avec
plus de 30 % des votes
tout au long de la campagne il s'est
présenté comme le candidat du changement
le leader de l'opposition libérale
entend s'imposer face au président
sortant en prenant les bienfaits d'une
pologne ouverte
[Applaudissements]
nous pouvons constater à partir de ce
résultat que beaucoup de polonais voit
ces cinq dernières années d'une manière
très différente de la nôtre et qu'ils
ont une opinion très positive de
certaines réformes introduites par le
pis je tiens à dire clairement à tous et
polonais n'oubliez pas que contrairement
à ceux qui détiennent le pouvoir
actuellement nous tirerons des
conclusions sur ce qui se passe en
pologne
[Applaudissements]
cette élection sera un choix entre ce
qu'ils disent citoyens qu'ils leur ont
donné quelque chose et ceux qui disent
qu'en pologne
nous devons tout à votre dur travail
[Musique]
selon une étude publiée à la sortie des
urnes ce dimanche pour la télévision tvn
duda pourrait espérer 45 5% des votes le
12 juillet prochain contre 44,7 pour
rafal trajkovski une estimation très
serré et qui révèle que presque 10 % des
polonais sont encore indécis sur leurs
choix entre changements et continuité
les polonais semblent divisés sur
l'issue de cette présidentielle
je voudrais que quelque chose change je
voudrais être sûr que rien ne me
surprendra que ma voix aura en ce sens
qu'elle sera prise en considération
je veux sentir que j'ai une influence
sur ce qui se passe autour de moi je
suis un membre de la nation polonaise
je voudrais le sentir on ne sait pas qui
va gagner
duda aux traces cops qui m'est
personnellement je ne vois que doudard
pour être président je suis pour la
continuité
je trouve que la situation est meilleure
qu'à une autre époque
une élection qui pourrait marquer un
tournant pour la pologne en cas de
victoire du maire de varsovie c'est
toute la formation politique du
président sortant qui en sortiraient
fragilisée dans le cas contraire la
victoire de duda devrait sceller
l'emprise du parti au pouvoir au moins
jusqu'aux prochaines législatives de
et pour en parler
nous sommes avec francesco rizzuto
professeur de droit européen
l'université de edge il bonsoir
francesco et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france le président
sortant en tête c'est pas vraiment une
surprise mais avec une telle avance on
pouvait s'y attendre à ce que sa
victoire était clair quelque chose car
il ya six semaines ou de mois on pensait
qu'ils gagneraient dès le premier tour
cela était peut-être trop optimistes
mais ça n'a pas été le cas
le film alors on sait si l'on
comptabilise celui là qui fait voir se
rend compte qu'il a obtenu 43 0 67%
mais si on ajoute les voix du maire de
varsovie et du présentateur de
télévision
[Musique]
ken 44 0 1% des voix donc si on prend le
centre droit sont le candidat civiques
et c'est de là que se pincer sont égaux
et il faut ensuite aller chercher
d'autres voies a donc ce n'est pas c'est
un très bon résultat
lorsqu'on perd une élection où lorsqu'on
ne se débrouille pas si bien qu'on
espérait il est facile de dire qu'on a
gagné
alors c'est vrai qu'en pologne aussi il
y avait le contexte de la crise
sanitaire est ce que ça a joué ça a pesé
pour vous sur les résultats de cette
élection le soutien du gouvernement ni
la magie du monde mais le système ne
donnait plus beau ne t'y pas que jacques
gens exactement à cette question au-delà
de la question
ni terres cette élection porte sur la
vue lumière de la pologne avec deux
piles sans vouloir être trop emphatique
auto dauphin et je pense que les gens
seront enfin que la pologne a quitté la
route
elle s'éloigne de l'europe occidentale
nous avons eu manifestation show
manifestation beaucoup de personnes se
rendent compte que la question
électorale c'est la faune m la nature
fondamentale de la pologne à vous dit
'le seynois s'éloigne de la route
occidentale qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire par là en quoi la pologne et
doit-elle de l'europe ont besoin
je vais vous donner s'inquiète car cinq
plaintes contre la pologne soit par la
pologne ou par la commission de l'union
européenne la pologne ne respecte plus
ses engagements selon l'article 2 du
traité de l'union européenne en deux
temps elle a une idée très étrange de
l'indépendance du système judiciaire
pour la pologne
hab effectuer une purge au sein du
judiciaire polonais cela fait 30 ans en
1991 et la chute du communisme
on disait que le système judiciaire
était communiste mais ce n'est pas le
cas ils ont même unité idéologique 4 de
la justice très désuète qui remonte à ce
qu'on pourrait qualifier d'ancien régime
deuxième exemple ils utilisent les
médias notamment les médias publics afin
je voudrais créer un état illusoire pour
les gens il y a également un troisième
exemple utiliser
les finances gouvernementales afin de
récompenser les personnes qui respectent
et leurs priorités et punir d'autres
personnes la nomination des juges la
perte d'indépendance des juges les
médias la pologne qui ignore
complètement la cour européenne de
justice
ils ont toujours leurs conceptions comme
faisant partie de l'europe qui remonte
aux années 1930
et c'est un véritable problème mais ils
ont de la chance parce que j'ai union
européenne fait confiance à la cour de
justice et à la commission n'ont pas de
conseils ou des gouvernement ne souhaite
pas et à utiliser l'article 7
il pourrait suspendre l'adhésion de la
pologne tout comme de l'hongrie de la
hongrie d'ailleurs merci
francesco risotto nous avoir apporté
votre analyse en direct sur rt france la
colère continue de monter en mer le
président brésilien jaillir humble
sudaro des manifestants de divers
groupes de gauche se sont réunis hier à
sao paulo pour protester contre le chef
d'état brésilien et surtout sa gestion
de la pandémie coronavirus il faut dire
que son pays le deuxième le plus meurtri
par la maladie après les états unis
la manifestation a été rejointe par des
militants du mouvement black like the
matters et sao paulo à la plus grande
ville d'amérique du sud est devenue
l'épicentre du virus au brésil
quatorze mille décès sont à déplorer
dans cet état du sud-est et la
population la plus touchée par le commis
19 reste celle qui vit dans les
quartiers défavorisés agusta à lombardie
avec hélène d'un masque relié à sao
paulo les vins quartier qui compte le
plus grand nombre de décès causés par le
cos vide se trouvent dans les zones
périphériques de la commune comme à
brazil andia à 15 km du centre ville
avec près de 300 morts ce territoire
devenu tristement célèbre pour son
record de victimes du corona virus la
perte de revenus également en raison de
la crise sanitaire aggravent la
situation des habitants nombreux ici
sont ceux qui dépendent de l'économie
informelle
et ne dispose pas de contrat de travail
le gouverneur de l'état de sao paulo a
donc autorisé depuis le 1er juin la
réouverture de plusieurs services non
essentiels de la ville je trouve que
l'ouverture des commerces et précoce car
les courbes de décès et de cas de
contamination n'ont pas cessé de monter
surtout dans les périphéries où on
manque parfois d'information les gens ne
croient pas que le virus soit aussi
mortelle sans parler du fait que
beaucoup d'habitants ici sont obligés
d'aller travailler pour avoir de quoi
manger tout simplement dans les favelas
ce et d'autres quartiers défavorisés
plusieurs produits d'hygiène sont
difficiles à se procurer il isolement
social est impossible à respecter
près de 40 % de la population
brésilienne n'a pas accès aux services
sanitaires de base notamment l'eau
potable dans de telles conditions le
simple fait de se laver est inconcevable
l'hôpital de brazil ando est en travaux
depuis plus de 14 ans
rapidement transformée en hôpital de
campagne il manque cruellement de moyens
les travaux ont été mises à l'arrêt il
ya 4 ans car la mairie disait ne pas
avoir assez d'argent ils l'ont donc
transformé en hôpital de campagne mais
il n'y a que 20 lits en unité de soins
intensifs c'est clairement une question
de négligence de la part des politiques
brasil en dia est un des quartiers
périphériques qui souffrent le plus au
brésil surtout quand il s'agit de santé
publique
au brésil plus de 13 millions de
personnes habitent dans les favelas face
à l'épidémie ces quartiers populaires
aux ruelles exigu sont des bombes à
retardement
l'épidémie continue de sévir dans le
pays qui compte plus de cinquante sept
mille décès le bilan le plus meurtrier
sur la planète après les états unis
mais pour en parler nous sommes avec
hervé théry docteur en géographie
professeur à l'université de sao paulo
bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous alors on a vu un
des manifestants qui ont planté un
millier de croix blanches dans la
capitale brasilia
hier sur l'esplanade des ministères est
ce que clairement on est dans un
tournant dans la crise les brésiliens
disent stop alors président une partie
d'entre eux oui mais le problème c'est
qu'il ya encore environ un tiers qui
sont derrière lui et qui refuse de
changer d'opinion et donc le pays est
très polarisée ce qui était inhabituel
dans son histoire blé ya vraiment des
gens qui continuent à le soutenir il ya
mais lui aussi militant le sujet une
manifestation contre lui à sao paulo
mais il y en a eu pour lui à brasilia
tout petit nombre de gens devant le
quartier général de l'armée et demandant
une intervention militaire donc on a des
gens des deux côtés et le pays vraiment
elle a eu à dire c'est vrai que vu de
france
vous allez nous expliquer ce qui se
passe parce que vu de france ça paraît
ahurissant 57 mille morts avec un
président qui sont minimisés le virus
ont des consignes alors que voilà on
enterre des gens partout comment et
pourquoi le président bernard o trouve
encore des partisans
voyez une partie des gens qui sous de
même avis que lui que c'était bien mieux
du temps de la dictature militaire lundi
vraiment des gens très très
réactionnaire et puis y ait des gens qui
ont voté pour lui par rejet du président
du précédent régime de parti des
travailleurs et qui ne veulent pas
admettre qu'ils ont fait une erreur donc
ils soutiennent contre vents et marées
que le président a raison même si ça
défie toute opinion faut aussi se
rappeler qu'on parle d'un pays 200
millions d'habitants de 16 fois plus
grand que la france et il ya des
situations très différentes les unes des
autres
une des régions les plus touchées celles
amazonie parmi les le nombre de cas par
millier d'habitants est très grave très
élevé parce que les gens habitent de feu
ses proches des rivières et circulant
bateau est là l'épidémie s'est répandue
comme une traînée tout en amazonie ça
veut dire que finalement c'est vrai que
nous on entre toujours les images voilà
des choses qui vont pas au brésil mais
que finalement le brésil ne ressent pas
autant qu'on peut le ressentir en france
en voyant les images cette crise du
coronavirus il ya des régions entières
où il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de cas mais
heureusement pour eux mais c'est en
train de s'étendre je suis géographe je
le suis tout ça sous forme de carte et
je vois tous les jours la can la carte
des des cas reconnus et beaucoup ne le
sont pas s'éteindre donc je crains que
les gens qui sont dans les régions pour
l'instant tranquille mais beaucoup de
soucis à ce mot france on a réussi à
circonscrire à peu près il ya des
régions françaises qui ont été très peu
touché j'ai peur que la façon dont on
s'y prend au brésil ça ne continue à
s'étendre
même dans des régions jusque là
relativement tranquille alors on l'a dit
à beaucoup de pauvreté je vais
volontairement poser cette question de
provocatrice est ce que finalement le
président brésilien at-il le choix est
ce qu'il aurait pu faire comme la france
qui est un pays riche confiné arrêté
l'économie pendant deux mois le temps
que la vrs marque le pas a été fait en
grande partie ils ont les confinements
commencé à peu près en même temps que
nous des parents droit probablement trop
tôt parce qu'au bout de tout ce temps là
les gens n'ont vraiment assez ils ont
vraiment besoin de gagner nos vies donc
c'est pas faute d'avoir essayé pour la
sexualité de façon fait de façon un peu
désordonnée
il ya des gens qui n'ont à aucun moment
respecter le confinement parce qu'il
devait gagner leur vie au jour le jour
pour se nourrir pour nourrir leurs
enfants
vous voyez des images tout à l'heure de
la zone est de sao paulo
il faut prendre conscience qu'il y à
quatre millions et demi d'habitants dans
cette ville dans cette partie de la vie
en ville fait 20 millions d'habitants et
4 millions et j'ai de pauvres gens qui
ont plus de revenus
il faut bien qu'ils fassent quelque
chose qui circule est donc que n'ont pas
vraiment eu le choix
alors on sent que les relations en tout
cas du président brésilien avec
l'injustice ce temps d'ailleurs exemple
anecdotique mais qui est intéressant ce
qui ne porte pas de masque dans un lieu
public jaillir ball sonar ou est
passible d'une amende de 340 euros enfin
l'équivalent en france en europe
une façon peut-être de la part du
pouvoir judiciaire de lui rappeler que
c'est un homme comme les autres qui est
soumis aux lois du pays
oui c'est là c'est la dernière barrière
législatif a pratiquement laissé toute
tentative de résister donc c'est en fait
les juges qui sont la dernière barrière
l'allemande dont vous parlez lui était
donnée par un juge du district fédéral
dont il est probable qu'il n'a pas
juridiction sur le président de la
république mais c'est une façon de les
rappeler à l'ordre
mais je pense que c'est inutile il fait
il fait provocation sur provocation je
pense qu'il ya aussi une tactique
délibérée depuis le premier jour son
élection d'empiler provocation sur
provocation ce qui ravit ses électeurs
comme trump le fait aux états unis et
qui a pas grand effet sur la marche des
choses à il ya un côté provocation il ya
un côté rideau de fumée
il ya un côté communication tout ça bout
à bout et donc comme ce sont des
symboles ces symboles contre symbole
merci beaucoup avait terrible docteur en
géographie et soeurs à l'université de
sao paulo d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rtl
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu prolonge
d'un an la mission des casques bleus au
mali la mission multi à dimensionner
d'intégrer des nations unies pour la
stabilisation au mali les minus ma
restera donc sur le terrain jusqu'en
juin 2021
depuis janvier 2005 580 civils ont
trouvé la mort souvent à cause de
conflit inter communautaire une année
supplémentaire donc lors de laquelle les
casques bleus renforceront leur
coopération avec les forces conjointes
du g5 sel et pour clément yao
journaliste et directeur de la
publication du magazine l'afrique
aujourd'hui c'est une bonne chose que
les casques bleus restent sains en plus
la prolongation c'est une issue
inévitable vu que le problème du mali
demeure intacte il n'a pratiquement pas
changé
et puisque les forces qui agissent sont
toujours l'action structurelles et un
des piles à présent des trois forces
militaires notamment la milice marque
mais j'ai qu'une g5 sahel et les phrases
partners barkan alors et ensemble plus
de cela il ya aussi haut niveau donc des
autorités politiques à une espèce de
contestation populaire qui a eu lieu il
ya quelques duos nationale tout se
mélange la paix la sécurité et aussi
d'un stabilité de ce pays
donc je pense que leur progression était
tout à fait normal et ir est nécessaire
c'est la fin de cette émission prochain
point complet sur l'actualité dans douze
minutes précisément à 22h rester avec
nous en direct sur rt falls
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et là on parle de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe que
ça veut dire
à côté cata strophe là il ya un tournant
mais on recevait à vivre mais dans une
autre direction c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité que pour
sauver des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais quel d'une décision
invraisemblable pour vos ça dépend
telles valeurs on attribuait la mort la
vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas c'est un débat n'aura
un débat éthique
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je suis
finissent par renoncer au soir vous avez
proposé deux posters en fallait que ça
veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
ça fait plus d'une vingtaine d'années
qu'un certain nombre d'événements
inattendus qui bouleverse cet ordre
mondial on essaie de le faire perdurer
mais on est à la fin d'un modèle qui
était le tout misé sur la dette
tu es la dette et la relance par la
dette ou par la création monétaire
c'est quelque chose qui a fonctionné
systématiquement on l'a dit des milliers
de fois c'est en imprimant des billets
que vous relancer une économie si on
essaie autant de relancer la croissance
économique s'est fondamentalement on
sait on sait pas faire sans fin son
économie ne peut pas continuer à
diffuser des chiffres qui sont
absolument faux simplement parce que ça
arrange monsieur trump à ce moment là
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie
trône ici malgré la polémique mondiale
sur l'efficacité de cette combinaison
nous avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les deux types euros qui
vient à manquer les must ne commence à
baisser
au sénégal la chloroquine de maillage
analysé pendant des décennies et des
décennies ça pourrait faire sourire les
sénégalais quand j'entends dire il n'y a
pas de signes qui m'est rendu
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce qui si c'est interdit
d'interdire